[Musique]
le 12 septembre diogo lopes joue
plusieurs fois au jeu monopoly et
remporte soudain de gros gains aux
alentours de 19 heures j'ai touché le
gros lot c'est à dire les hisseront
mille francs ma mère elle est arrivée à
la maison à 21 bat jeter en train de lui
montrer le jeu et j'ai un nouveau touché
les 100 mille francs 210 mille euros au
total le rêve va durer 48 heures
jonathan joue pour 4000 euros
[Applaudissements]
pas mal c'est peut-être pas mal
mais non
attendez
[Musique]
l'autorité suisse des jeux d'argent
informe que les gains ne seront pas
versées la faute à un incident technique
pendant une opération de maintenance du
site la loterie romande n'est pas
contractuellement tenue ni légalement
autorisés à payer des gains qui ne
seraient pas prévus par le plan des lots
approuvé par l'autorité de surveillance
des jeux d'argent comme diego lopes
297 joueurs ont été victimes de cet
ascenseur émotionnel une toulonnaise qui
début août a remporté six mille euros en
jouant au keno joli gain belles émotions
et pour fêter sa belle décide le
lendemain de jouer au loto il fait
jamais d'habitude et bien comme pour le
keno elle joue ses numéros fétiches et
c'est à nouveau le jackpot 6 millions
d'euros au loto c'est toile en résumé en
deux jours elle a gagné au keno et au
loto un gain total de 6 millions et 6000
euros une sacrée chance les mauvaises
langues auraient tendance à douter de
l'élite et 2 sont mariés
[Musique]
6 heures je sais pas comment je pourrais
faire sans elle sans mes copines
mais bahia gervais légèreté m'occupe des
deux compagnies mais bon faut pas que je
le dise trop alex fait après avoir je
suis folle h 40 donc il sait pas que
j'ai nommé mes machines à laver ce à
quoi
tu as appelé germaine est plutôt
de combien de temps vraiment libre sans
travail sans tâche ménagère at on besoin
chaque jour pour être heureux mon bras
sans surprises dans les résultats n'ont
justement plus le temps libre augmente
plus le bien-être augmente mais comme
pour toute bonne chose il ya une limite
pour être heureux nous aurions très loin
après ces bruits exactement entre 2 et 5
heures de temps libre par jour au delà
de cinq heures et ben la courbe du
bien-être redescend et oui l'ennui vous
guette savoir dire bonjour et que les
enfants sont en bonne santé
mais raymond et ressaisis toi allez
arrêtez moi si vos enfants ils sont en
mauvaise santé ça vous tue votre vie
vous avez pu nous aimons n'est pas là
dedans a dit pas la santé ce qui est
important oui et prostituées
ouais
pour une fois j'étais subtil mélange pas
mais vous ne l'avez pas compris merci
mais non j'avais sous texte mais vous
voulez je sais que vous êtes subtil mais
c'est pas si fréquent que mon on est bon
on retourne au salon en scooter pour
certaines
pas forcément une bonne idée d'ailleurs
très fracassante ans quand elle est là
son postérieur ses imposants et donc on
voit tout cela c est là
si je peux me dire un mot q comme l'arc
de triomphe chinois indiquant
qu comme quoi elle a un cul comme la
triumph oui mais chez nous on dit comme
la porte d'aix
je me souviens quand j'ai joué la
première fois où tu café théâtre j'avais
un meneur un mois de même chaud où
j'étais en mini jeu que j'avais des
cuisses assez assez ronde c'est vrai
qu'il avait pas d et la critique qui est
venu la première d'un d'une journaliste
d'un canard pour femmes de mode c'était
l eau se mettre en minijupe alors
qu'elle a déconstruit donc les femmes
sont déjà souvent les premières gardiens
de l'ordre machiste
angie dépit
jti
et british
energy be this you
qu'est ce que vous dites en envoyant le
jeune pénible vous êtes resté fidèle à
ce que vous étiez à ce moment là ou pas
non mais moi j'ai changé de look mais
j'ai jamais changé de personnalité moi
j'ai toujours été comme ça ma femme m'a
fait enlever les boucles d'oreille de
moi je me faisais traité de vache qui
rit donc c'était pas bête
parce qu'il faut c'est que tu prête bien
au hockey et tu vas serré je sers dans
roue et en bas voilà
c'est nickel et moi je m'occupe de toi
turluter mais absolument un autre nom et
merci à vos caroline et à ce soir c'est
à l'air c'est dans le hall
ici on à quoi pouvait remporter à
des fautes d'orthographe ça c'est
quelque chose que je retrouve souvent à
accent emporté er
bon mais jamais vu ça le mec qu'on a
l'impression qu'ils travaillent au soit
irrite où il encore plus fort que les
portiques dans les aéroports le mec dans
notre vie doit être détecteur de
portique c'est pas possible et puis on
peut devenir très vite qu'on s'a c'est
une des conclusions vous faites et ce
sera entièrement de ma faute parce que
ma famille elle a fait tout bien ben
voilà eh bien on ne nous excusera pas si
vous le dirai et je vous le dirai mais
dans combien de temps du ramadan du
silence sur la question s'est pas tu
crois tu pas du genre à chercher les
saladiers chaque fois je pose la
question talent est bon là
qu'est ce qu'il a écrit et des mets tes
lunettes
je montre ce que c'est et dis moi
combien c'est un homme politique un
homme tout simplement un être humain il
a pris tellement de coups qui cherchent
là où il est donc ils assurent fêlures
il ya une cassure garder ben j'ai eu le
coach compte pour mais c'est vrai bazin
a écrit la tuerie condamné mais quand il
est une question majeure à kasserine a
dit pas s'ils voyagent pas de change de
femme
ça mais je sais tu as pris conscience
que c'est quand même de cuisine belle tu
as construit c'est un projet aux copains
aux problèmes en cuisine ok ok c'est bon
j'arrête là
mes amis ici présents se joignent à moi
pour vous sans moi c est vous souhaiter
une très belle après midi sur deux
[Applaudissements]
non